so hello everybody I am in Salem South
Carolina as you can see it's nice and
warm here I am going to be giving an
icon carving class this week and for the
beginning of this session there's an
icon carving class and an icon painting
class as well given by someone else I
was asked to give the opening talk and I
decided to do it on the on the let's say
radical solution that making Christian
and especially the surgical art offers
to our culture and so I hope you enjoy
this just so you know like I've told you
before I've started making patron only
videos and so this month of the month of
September I'm going to make a patron
only video interpreting the story of
Rumplestiltskin ah it is one of my
favorite stories because it's so strange
but I think there's a lot of interesting
stuff we can get in there I will also
look down into the description of this
video because I will put the date and
the place where I will be speaking in
Chicago very soon I will also be
speaking at st. Econ seminary in
Pennsylvania near Scranton Pennsylvania
in the month of November so if you're to
sit in that I would put the details in
there down below as well so enjoy the
video and every guys I will talk to you
soon
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
I was asked to give a definition of an
icon and so an icon is a sacred image so
the word icon is complicated because the
word icon just means image and so it's
not it we it's a shorthand right when we
use the word icon what we mean is sacred
image so we don't we don't say sacred
but that's what we're talking about so
that's what makes the icon particular
it's because it is an image which not
only depicts sacred things holy people
but also is sacred in the sense that it
participates in the life of the church
it participates in the life of the
liturgy as well and so it is another
word we could use is something like
liturgical image that's another way that
we could talk about it and so because of
because of what it is because it is a
sacred image it has certain
characteristics which grew up in the
church and the tradition of the church
to help identify the images to help
differentiate them from secular images
and to help us understand what it is
that's going on inside the image and so
in terms of the the actual canons you
could say in terms of what the church
has decided it is required for something
to be considered a sacred image you need
to have an image of person a holy person
and you need to have the name of the
person which is which is written on the
image and that is actually in the
seventh ecumenical council the the basic
strict minimum of what it takes to for
us to recognize that's this okay so this
image is something it's the image of a
saint it's the image of Christ it's the
image of the mother of God and if we put
the name there so that there's no
mistake we know who it is we're
interacting with and that image is there
to help us participate in the liturgy
participate in participate in the sense
to interact with the person that is
being represented
and I think that that that's going to
slowly kind of bring me to what it is
that I mostly wanted to talk to you
about as I'm talking I'll give a little
bit of characteristics of the icon but
what I mostly want to bring people to
think about right now is is the
particular moment that we are in in
terms of culture in terms of Western
culture Christian post Christian culture
we're at a point in in our history where
we have we're very cultural right we
have a lot of cultural events you know
if you if you all the cities they'll
organize different cultural events and
what's interesting if you pay attention
to what we now call culture today what
is it like going to a concert you know
going to the theater watching a movie
all of these things with what describes
them is that they are entertainment that
we have come to a point in our own story
where we have reduced what we call
culture to entertainment to something
which you sit passively and you look at
you you you watch a movie or you listen
to music and you you passively encounter
something and what's interesting about
the icon and what's it's not the only
thing that's interesting but what's
fascinating if you think about it in the
context of our social moment right now
is that it's actually a way into a more
profound and authentic way to engage
with what we call culture that is the
images if you think of how modern art
developed you know from let's say
especially from the time of the
romantics up to today we really have
this idea and you'll meet artists today
you know fine artists whose what is what
did they want what is their hope they
that they hope that their art can be
shown in a gallery and that they can
maybe have a nice catalog published with
their images in them and that people
with a lot of money will collect their
art put them in their collections so
that then when they get shown in museums
then they could have you know
you know where the provenance is though
in this in this famous collection so we
have a series of cultural art of
cultural artifacts we have artists
galleries museums right and all of these
are there for you to go and look at art
or buy art and collect it okay
now this is where you can see the
difference between the icon but the icon
is going to be in this in this
particular example a window into an
ancient world which is now gone which
has slide Li not completely gone but
it's a it's slowly fading away when
you're making an icon you are not making
the icon to go into a gallery there are
a few artists sadly there are a few
iconographer who wish that's how it was
but usually when we make an icon why are
we making the icon we usually usually -
usually two reasons I mean very
practical reason I mean that practical
reasons usually it's because you're
practicing or because you've been
commissioned that loses it two reasons
why you make an icon like either you're
trying to get better and make better
icons so you're you're learning you're
you're improving your your your craft or
someone asks you and said I need an icon
of Saint Dimitri I need an icon of
Christ of this feast of this and that's
when you make an icon I don't I don't I
make a very few icons once in a while
I'll make a conscious like that but most
of the time if I make an icon I'm making
an icon for someone that's huge it's a
huge difference so huge difference if
you think about the artists in their
studio who's expressing themselves and
then one hopes to show their work in a
gallery in hopes that their work will
become famous I am creating something
for someone's particular need that is
it's like making a chair right I'm
making something for someone but it's
bigger than that the very particular
transaction is that someone writes me
calls me talks to me and says you know
my my nephew is being baptized and I
would like to offer an icon of this
Saint
something like that and so there's a
story there it's a human story there's a
human story of someone who has a need a
church that has a need someone who wants
to celebrate something and so I am
engaging them in that story but then at
the bigger level what I'm also doing is
I'm participating in a communal act and
participating in a communal language
that is the language of the icon as
you'll see those who are painting those
who are carving you'll see it's a very
specific language and it's specific for
spiritual reasons for theological
reasons but there's also another reason
why it's specific it's specific because
it is a communal language just like any
just like English is it just like the
spoken languages are communal languages
that is when I'm saying something to to
James I want him to understand what I'm
saying I'm trying to communicate
something I want to engage with him and
when we make an icon we are entering it
into a community into a church into a
whole history and a whole community of
people that recognize these images there
are other traditional arts and other
cultures that have that of course you
know you think of you think of that now
I'm not like into musical instrument
making musical instruments is a great
example of that where you are making a
musical instrument for someone that's a
very high quality it so it has to be
beautiful it has to you know you really
want it to be the best but it also has
to do what it has to play music and it
has to sound right so that person can
then play music with his band and so
that's the same thing it's very similar
to when we make an icon we are we're
making an object within a language
within a community for a community and
we're all so we're so we're
participating in this whole also this
whole strand of history we're connecting
ourselves to a community but to the past
all this is a connected language so now
contrast that with the the state of
secular art where we are
now they don't succeed in doing it but
usually a lot of the famous artists
today the way that they get attention is
by shocking by doing something that no
one has seen before you know is it
innovative like is it innovation has
somehow become a core value of culture
for some reason the idea that you should
do something that no one has seen before
and why so they're appealing to
something very different it's something
very very different
this desire to titillate right the
desire to surprise to shock to to to
provoke a disjunction in culture and if
you look at modern art from especially
from the 20th century now you look at
the modern artists their particular goal
was to create constant dis junctions to
to break what was there before so the
Cubist tried to break the classicists
and then you know the surrealist came
and said all these formulas no we're
going to break that with this kind of
broke it this exploded imagination the
Dada
came in and they said we're gonna break
the whole thing we're gonna smash the
entire the entire system and and that's
our that's the background of the way
that we think about culture today you
know if you if you watch a movie that
gets great great reviews usually they'll
say oh this is new this has some kind of
there's something you've never seen
before it's innovative and everything
now there's nothing wrong with
innovation right it's very it's very
dangerous as I'm going down this road
I'm thinking he's all he's he's saying
you can't innovate no there's no nothing
wrong with innovating but the question
is always when you're making icons you
always have to think firstly that you
want to integrate this image into
community so it's not that there's
something wrong with innovating but the
question is why would you innovate you
have to have a reason there has to be
something which would make you change
what you're doing because if I'm trying
to communicate something to you and I'm
trying to engage you you know if I'm
trying to to find out how your day went
I'm not going to make up a new word that
would be stupid
because I mean and there's nothing wrong
with making up new words if there's a
reason to
but unless there's a reason to what you
want to do you want to focus on the
purpose the purpose of what you're
communicating the purpose of what you're
doing and that's what you find in in
iconography so once you realize that
there's actually something there's a
there's a strange little moment now also
in culture is that we've kind of you
know I said that most of our culture is
let's say it's entertainment and passive
but there's actually quite a lot of the
passive culture which is trying to be
transformed into active participation so
there's some I'll give you an example
this is this is the the most one of the
funniest examples there's something in
the United States it's a pretty large
organization it's called Harry Potter
and the sacred texts and what it is it's
basically a church so people will meet
every week
and they'll have readings group readings
of Harry Potter books so let's sit
together and then they'll have a group
reading of a Harry Potter book and then
they'll have a discussion about it I
don't know I've never been to an one of
those events I can't just come I'm sorry
this is really real you can look up say
Harry Potter or the sacred text okay but
it's only one example of several other
things like that like you have something
called you probably have heard of
cosplay where people will dress up as
their favorite comic book movie
characters and then they'll go to these
events and they'll they'll be costume
and they'll like celebrate their their
faith their favorite fiction characters
together in these these these almost
liturgical events okay
now what you're seeing what you're
seeing is we're seeing the end we're
seeing the the end of the passive
entertainment culture or not that
totally the end but we're seeing it
start to fray in these types of
movements where people it's as if
they're they're lacking something they
want participative culture because
that's what ancient culture used to be
like think about you know a village too
years ago 300 years ago what was culture
culture was you know Mardi Gras and Lent
and then we had the feast of this Saint
in the feast of that Saint and then we
would have processions and we had folk
dancing all of these were participative
there was we didn't have this idea that
culture was just sitting there and
watching someone else perform something
not that it was excluded but that that's
not wasn't the core of culture yeah yeah
now social media is an interesting is a
very interesting thing in terms of
community is that it is social media is
a parody of community because what we've
had in let's say the past hundred years
we've developed this idea of the
celebrity right the celebrity has
replaced the saint we're not not idiots
it's pretty obvious we call them stars
you know we call them icons we use all
the words that that we would use to
describe Saints they replace them and so
but it's an invert obviously an inverted
form of sainthood where it's whoever can
titillate or shock or surprise or
attract that kind of carnal attention
you could say is the one who wins the
game but so but but now there is this
desire to participate but it's it's in
the image of that strange that strange
inverted thing so social media if you
think of Facebook the way it works or
Twitter the same thing we have the sense
that it's somehow a form of community
but it's not really what it is it's
basically people who are showing
themselves and then other people who can
watch right so it's it's it's many many
stars so it's it's it's basically
exposing yourself and voyeurism
so you can look at some you can what you
can go on someone's facebook page you'll
never know right they'll never know that
you're looking at them unless you write
a comment but it's like so it's so so
I'm gonna show pictures of myself some
people can look at them and so it's like
it's a mini form of this the stardom
that we have like a little mini form of
it and it's it's a parody of it's a
parody of community now I'm on social
media like I'm not
saying you should be on social media how
about social media it's useful and
everything and I think it's important to
understand the moment in culture where
we are and like I said all these these
things like let's say these these kind
of cosplay worlds all these two and also
videogames are part of it too
videogames are part of trying to create
participative places where where you're
not only receiving culture but you're
actually engaging with in an actual
narrative but what's what's interesting
about what we're doing and this is the
most this is why iconography liturgical
art is in a way the most radical thing
that you can do right now because the
question is posing or the challenge that
exposing to culture it goes very very
deep goes right at the root of our
entire culture of entertainment and of
passive that's an aesthetic experience
and so that's why you look at you know
someone like mark and myself there's
other iconographer in North America who
were actually trained in contemporary
art we were all trained in contemporary
art trying to be gallery artists all of
this and reaching let's say the end of
that it seems like the only place to go
that was the only place to go was this
desire for a participative culture and
the the icon offers that in every way
now when I talk about the icon it's very
carrot we have to be very careful not to
not to disassociate it from everything
else that is the icon only has its full
meaning its whole purpose when it's part
of the community when it's part of
communion in the largest sense when it's
part of the liturgical life of the
church and so it's not you can't it's
very we're used to thinking of these
objects as paintings because we're
that's how we think that it's it's hard
to break that we make these paintings we
put them on the wall like that that's it
there's nothing like I said
there's nothing wrong with that but it's
important to understand that this has
it's part of an entire that say an
entire work of art I always say that the
the composer vogner in at the end of the
19th century he had a term I probably
not be able to say it and it had a term
which meant the perfect work of art and
he said this is opera because opera has
all the different arts in in it it has
visual art in terms of the scenery and
in terms of composition it has music in
it and so and it also has narrative it
has drama and so he said this is the
perfect it's the perfect work artists to
complete work of art but there was one
thing missing right what was missing
that was participation right that's what
was missing in Wagner's is it
consumption I mean you're not new and
say it then it was the perfect work of
art and the the perfect work of art is
more something like the liturgical year
that is the perfect work of art because
for it covers the entire narrative first
of all that we participate in the
narrative of Christ's life that we that
we engage in that we try to emulate and
participate in it also includes all
those things that vogner talked about
which is we have the music we have the
visual aspect we have like I said we
have the narrative we also have
architecture which father didn't have we
also have the actual space itself is is
thought out and that's why that's why
the Orthodox tradition has done us such
a service by preserving the basic
grammar of the Christian language it has
it has offered us the possibility to
once again participate in this full
language and it's hard to do in our
modern world we're all we're also also
alienated even though we're Orthodox
were not we're not like in a Greek
village you know five hundred years ago
but we do have this door that is open to
us and like I said
the fact that we always have to remember
that the icons are not just painted
boards there are images inside the
church the placement of the icons in the
church is coherent it's not arbitrary
we put certain image it's not always the
same it's not a hundred percent it's not
a system but it is always theologically
proposed that is images the images speak
to themselves within the church the
images also speak to themselves across
different icon types and that's
something that we always have to
remember just like the the person who is
excited to read you know Marvel Comics
and to see references to other Marvel
comics in their Marvel Comics and to see
how all of these you know go to watch an
Avengers movie and to see all the
different superheroes that they like
come together into an Avengers movie
like look at the icon of the Last
Judgement right that's the ultimate
Avengers movie you have every single
story from Adam and Eve right all the
way to the last to to the final moment
of the whole universe all put into one
image in the icon of the Last Judgement
we have the ascension we have the we
have the the basic Babli we have all
these different images that are that are
kind of brought into one and then all
the other icons also talk to each other
so there's this inter this is a fancy
word but this intertextuality that we
that exist within the icons but the
icons are not just talking to themselves
they're also referencing the liturgy
they're referencing Scripture and so all
of this is like this massive grammar
this massive sacred grammar of things
that are talking to themselves and we
are part of that that massive poetic
language and that's why the actual
architecture of the church is also
important because it lets say just in
terms of iconography that there are
different ways you can make a church but
they say the basic Orthodox Church with
the dome and and the square well there's
a reason why Christ is up in the dome
and that you have a hierarchy of angels
or that you
have the saints who are watching Christ
to send all of these things are related
to what the dome is the dome is the dome
effect what happens in the West in the
church
it'll be irrelevant it'll be the
Dormition of the mother of god be the
Last Judgement something which
represents the end that son that sets if
you look at the East then you see the
child Christ who is coming out of the
mother of God's womb so you have the
dawn you have the the dawn and the Sun
rising out of the east and the Sun set
in the West so the whole church is is a
cosmic image and all these icons are
speaking to themselves the hymns all of
that goes together and so that is what
I'm trying to propose to people is that
what I'm finding now is that for a lot
of the young people like the people in
their 20s these are one that I'm in
contact with that is a very very
attractive thing because they've reached
the end of nope
they've reached the end of their world
like they they've plagued hundreds and
hundreds of hours of video games and
they're they're tired right they they're
tired of that empty desire that desire
to participate which always leaves you
somewhat empty and they they they love
all these all these mangas and all these
comic books and all this kind of pop
culture but they also realize that
there's something missing and to be able
to propose this beauty it's you like
I've given you some images some some
some hints of what's going on in let's
say this gigantic grammar this gigantic
story that we have in the Christian
tradition but it's inexhaustible it is
inexhaustible because it starts at
Genesis and it ends today and ends in to
the end of the world but like we're part
of it too and all these Saints are part
of the - the whole movement of history
is part of it - so you have this you can
participate you can be inside a story
and that has that has so much value for
people today anyways I that what I've
seen is young people
who are thirsty to have something to
participate in and so when we paint the
icons we need to understand that the the
codes that say that the norms of the
icons are not arbitrary they are there
first of all to make that image the most
participative it can be to make the
image of the saint bring you into
communion with that saint in the in the
best way right there's been a lot of
discussion about style some of you will
be aware of this so you will not be
aware of it but within the world of
iconography has been a massive debate
over style for like the last 50 years
maybe and and it's still raging today
it's still raging today but when you
when you look at the image as this
desire to commune to commune with the
tradition commune with the people to
commune with the the church that a lot
of those problems are less urgent
because the the decisions that you make
are not only stylistic they're also
they're like I said so that people will
understand what it is that you're trying
to do so I'm not gonna solve this
idealistic problem for you today but in
terms of understanding why there's a
halo understanding why the Saints are
looking at you usually either straight
on or 3/4 all of this is part of this
right we don't show an icon the Saint
with the back of their head why because
because of what I said the image is
there for you to engage with it it's not
there for you to just to just look at
how nicely well done the painting was
done and there's nothing wrong with that
- there's nothing wrong with the
beautifully painted icon that's not that
that's not the first reason why it
exists in the world
so anyways I'm not going to speak
forever I just was hoping to give you
that little little thought and to maybe
under to help us realize that as we're
sitting there at a table
and we're trying to figure out how to
paint the face or pick you know this you
know just the actual technical part that
we're all so even if suddenly working
toward the world where there's a renewal
of participative culture renewal of the
capacity to enter into a story and it's
the best story right it's the best story
cuz it's the story of Christ it's the
best story so thank you so I don't know
if anybody has any questions yeah just
occurred to me you know what you've been
saying we come to come into church and
come to the icon we kiss we are maybe
without realizing that engaging
ourselves
yeah but I think I think that when we
when we reverence an icon when we
venerate an icon we have to at least
that's the way I understand it the way I
understand it is it's the same way as
when in church the priest will come out
and he'll bow before us we bow before
the priest you know we we we are that is
the way we engage with ourselves and so
when you encounter an icon it's not just
an image right it's an image of a person
it's an image of a story it's an image
of an event in the life of Christ or in
the life of a saint that is extremely
meaningful to us and so by by venerating
it we're doing this like I said we're
doing the same thing we're recognizing
how God is manifesting himself through
that like when you bow down before
someone it's like your back you're not
just if I bow down before in church if I
if the Deacon is in sensing and I bow
before the priest they are not bowing
before you know Bob I mean yes but it's
not that's not the point the point is
that is that I'm bowing before the image
of Christ which is which is appearing
through him as we are in this this space
of communion and so the icon is also the
same it's like when we look at the image
obviously we're looking past the actual
paint we're seeing the saint and where
were ultimately we're actually looking
past the saint to a certain degree where
we're seeing Christ in that Saint right
where everything leads to Christ the
whole all of communion all of the
liturgy everything all the icons all of
this all leads to the image of Christ
which is appearing and it's different as
sparks in the different people around us
and the different events around us does
that make sense
you have a question music I mean I think
that I think that first of all there's
that there's like an objective aspect I
think that just like in church there's a
sacramentality which is not dependent on
the individual of you know the
individuals particular moment right now
it's like the sacraments are valid no
matter what the priest even the priest
the jerk whatever like the sacraments
are valid and I think that in a certain
manner that goes the same for an icon we
have to be careful we have to be careful
about that because you hear people say
things like because you know this icon
was painted by this guy who's you know
he's not in the church barely in the
church or you know whatever that's
dangerous because the image with the
name if that image come is part of the
let's say part of the language of the
church you know it can participate in
the life of the church and so that's
important that's important to understand
now on top of that let's say on top of
that there is then the more mystical
aspect which is there also in the
sacramentality of the church you can go
to church and then you can have this
amazing moment right this amazing grace
where you're transported where you you
you can feel the grace of God you know
just being funneled down into you and I
think it's the same for when we
encounter an icon and I think it's the
same for when you're making an icon so
there are moments when I've been making
icons where I was like not there at all
where I was completely and I was
fighting with my wife or you know our
financial problems and this is what's
going on and you know I finished the
icon and someone loves it says it's
beautiful it's whatever it's like that
wasn't me that wasn't me for sure like I
didn't know what that was beyond me but
there are other moments when you
our carving or paint I'm not I don't
paint but let's say you're carving the
icon and then you really have these
first of all you can have these very
strange moments in terms of encountering
the sink that you are painting or that
you're carving that has happened to me
oh very oddly where I'm making an image
of a saint and then all of a sudden all
these strange events you know regarding
this saint start to appear and all of a
sudden the saint is everywhere for some
reason it's like I hear people talking
about that st. er you see I mean all
kinds of different you know you go to
you go somewhere and then there's some
strange story that the saint has been
here or something like that so that is
something that can definitely happen to
you and as happened to me several times
and then also I think that in the best
moments I think that making an icon can
also be a prayerful act because you are
you are it's a you're participating in
the life of the church as you're making
the image now you you are you're making
something for the church if you're doing
it in a spirit of service and humility
you know and you're connected to to the
Saints then I think that you can also
have just these moments of of grace you
know these moments of peace these
moments of so yeah I'm sure can go
pretty far I'm sure if we were Saints we
might have visions of the saint and I'm
sure it could go a lot further than that
sadly I'm not quite there yet
does anybody have questions for those
who have come maybe for the first time
do you have questions on why icons look
the way they do yoga will will be also
giving people are we talking about it in
our in our class as well okay talking
about different different just the some
of the more like the codes you could say
like there are certain things in icons
which you need which we which we
traditionally put in icons for us to to
engage with them properly and to
recognize them so all right well thank
you for your attention and I wish
everybody a great week and it's it's
it's tough you know it gets it gets hard
especially after a few days and so well
well hopefully you can all in the
morning we'll have morning prayers and
put ourselves in the right track for the
day if you enjoy the symbolic world
content there's a lot of things you can
do to help us out
you're not subscribed please do go ahead
and share this to all your friends if
you can get involved in the discussion
we have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com